Test
.
[Captioner
caption test]
>> Attention. We're going
to be starting in about five
minutes.  Apologies.
We have an author in transit.
We'll be
starting in just a minute.
>> Good morning. Any time I
have the opportunity to kick
off one of these events I always
feel
like I should apologize
for interrupting the party.
Welcome to the Library of
Congress.
I'm Leanne Potter.
I direct educational outreach
here.  I'm
thrilled to welcome you here, to
the Symposium on Diversity in
Children's Literature and, of
course,
window
We Need Diverse Books.
If you want to clap, feel
free.
[Applause]
This program is being live
streamed.  I want to give a
shout-
shout-out to all who are at a
distance, especially those in
time
zones other than ours.  You
know, it's 9:00 here.  The folks
in
Chicago are watching.
The folks in
in other places watching.  I
want to thank them for watching.
And finally, my colleagues
making that happen.  Live
streams
and lights and so forth don't
happen by themselves.  Thanks to
Mike and my colleagues for
making that.
Here, we have three buildings
named for our founding fathers.
The building we're in this
morning is the James Madison
building
building.
For those of you who came in
downstairs on the first
floor, if you looked over to
your left you would have seen a
statue of James mod son Madison.
If you walked into the rooms you
could
have seen some of this quotes on
the walls.  They're engraveed
down there.  There's one that
speaks to the Library of
Congress
and to culture cultureal
institutions like the library.
I'm going to
paraphrase it.
It reads learned institutions
ought to be
favorite objects with every free
people.
They throw light over
the public mind.
I love that.
They throw light over the public
mind.
Even as Kathie and Ellen and I
were first discussing this
program last summer, I had a
lunch this
would be a light- -- I had a
hunch this will be a light
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
light-throwing event.
You all need to know when I
describe the library to people
who do not know much about it, I
often talk it about being a
place that sparks ideas.  The
primary sources in the
collections
collections, my colleagues, the
architecture of the Thomas
Jefferson building all inspire
creativity and imagine and help
us have possibilities.
A minute ago we were talking
about throwing light.  And I
just mentioned sparks.
When Kathie asked me if I would
introduce our moderator, I did a
little research about her.
Immediately, I thought, wow,
serendipity.  This author is
perfect.
Her website has a fabulous URL.
This morning's
moderator is Linda Sue Parker.
L.S. Park.
If you go to her website you'll
find the URL, L.
LSPARK.  Huh?
Magic.
Linda was born in urbanna,
Illinois.  She grew up in
Chicago
and earned her bachelor's degree
at Stanford University.  She
has authored numerous novels and
picture books for children.
She.
Often uses innovative forms to
expand young reader's sense
of possibility.
Her poetry collection, Tap
Dancing on the Roof utilizes a
Korean Sylabbic verse form.
Her novels for teenage readers
include a Single Shard, When My
Name Was KYOKO, and a Long Walk
to Water, based on a true story.
Her picture books include Fire
Keeper'S Son, and Bee BIM Bop.
She lives with her family in
Rochester, New York.  I have a
feeling she's just who we need
to start throwing some light on
our program this morning.
Please join me in welcomeing
Linda Sue
Parker.
[Applause]
>> LINDA: Good morning.
I am already having so much fun.
I'd like to thank the Library of
Congress
and, the Walter Award
Award's judging panel and
including all of you online.
I serve on the adviseory board
of We Need Diverse Books.  I'm
so thrilled to be the moderator
of today's symposium.
We have the power of books.  I'm
guessing if you're in this
room you have a story or two
about the power of books.
A couple of quick ones of minute
-- of mine.  My daughter is
named
after a character in one of
Charlotte's books.  Several
years
ago I moved to Brooklyn because
of: A Tree Grows in Brooklyn.
[Laughter]
Perhaps most important I
survived a childhood of being
different, in part because of
the strength books gave me.
This morning, I am delighted
to introduce the three winners
of
of The Walter honor awards whose
work turn the power of words
into a juggernaut.
Margarita Engle is the national
young
people's laure a at, e
and the first Latina to receive
that honor.
She  She has a previous
Walter honor for enchanted heir,
and many other awards.  I
decided I couldn't keep listing
the rest of them.
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
[Laughter]
She is the U.S.
nominee for the
2018 ester Lingraan award
award.
She has the 2018 Walter title
for young readers.
Margarita Engle.
[Applause]
Mitali
-- Mitali Perkins was born in
India and has lived in
Bangladesh, India, England,
Thailand, Mexico, and Ghana.
She is
a lectureer at Saint Mary's
college of California.  She's
the
author of You Bring the Distant
Near, a 2018 Walter honor book
for older readers.
Where's Mitali?  There she
is.
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Francisco X.
Stork is a -- is author of
Disappeared.  She's
also the author of the Last
Summer of the Death Warriors,
and
winner of the Amelia Elizabeth
Walden award.  He lives outside
Boston and he is the author of
Disappeared, a 2018 Walter honor
book for older readers.
[Applause]
Okay.
We're going to start with the
panelists as reader pass
pass.
So my first
.  First, I'd like to ask you to
think back to your
childhoods and where did your
book comes from?  Were you
school
library attendees?  Your school?
Your parents?  How do you have
access to books when you were
young?
>> For me, it was the public
library, in north east Los
Angeles, and I would go every
Saturday and get a stack.  But I
have to say that I read more
adult books than children's
books.
That's because I wanted
international books.  I wanted
books
about other countries.  And at
that time, there weren't books
about other countries for
children.
So I would go in in in the adult
travel section, which was
illegal.
The librarians would chase
me away.
[Laughter]
They thought I was supposed
to stay in the children's
section, but I would get
anything about geography and
travel and
other countries that I could
find.
>> Wonderful. Mitali?
>> Mitali: Yes, definitely
the
public library in Flushing
Queens.  Yeah, Flushing.  Yeah.
We immigrated there when I was
seven.
I come from a family that's
immigrant and refugee.  My
family left everything in the
war, left Bangladesh.  When we
came to the United States, we
had very little, so we had no
books in the home, but me and my
two
sisters, me all speak Ben
Bengali, we walked ten blocks to
the Flushing branch.  When we
walked in she said, you can take
seven books home.  I thought,
is this Alibabb's cave?
[Laughter]
So that's when I started
reading.
>> I grew up in Mexico. My
mother was a single mother so we
lived in my grandfather's house.
There was one book in his
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
bedroom in this old glass thing.
I knew where the key was hid
hiding.
He had 20 volumes of a book of
like treasures for youth
youth.
It was a compileation of fiction
and stories, science,
you could learn a language if
you learned those stories
careful
carefully.  That's how I went
through those books.  I don't
think I saw my library, a
library, until we moved to Texas
when
I was nine years old.
>> You think about that. I
think about all the places in
the world, even in our own
country where young people don't
have
access to a library.  How do
they live?  You know?
I mean -- --
[laughter]
It's really interesting.
Could you talk about the first
teem -- the first time, it may
not have been from your
childhood, but the first time
you felt
seen or heard in a book?
>> Francisco: I grew up with
this identity of being Mexican
for a long time.
I didn't become an American
citizen until I
was 26.
So it was really -- it was
really the authors from
Latin America that I just kind
of grew up with and it was only
when I was -- it was only when I
was in college and I had -- I
realized now I had lived 15
years in the United States and I
had
gone through learning a a new
language and getting paddleed
for
speaking Spanish in the
playground and getting rejected
by the
beautiful Becky because I was
Mexican.
[Laughter]
There were certain things that
were a little bit different
than Mexicans and I think it was
a little bit like where I kind
of saw, you know, this
possibility of
this -- this kind of looks
a little more like me.
>> Mitali?
>> Mitali: Yeah, I wanted
books because I didn't like
being
seen.  I moved to California in
7th grade and I was the only
kid of color in the whole school
and the only kid not born in
the USA in the whole school.
Books was a way for me to see
another life.  I was doing that
code switching at school.  I
used the curling iron to try to
transform myself into Farrah Fac
Farrah Facett every morning.
[Laughter]
I tried to look like
everybody else and I never did.
I feel
books is a way to see and
imagine other lives, which I
feel is a
huge advantage we get when we
have to cross borders to read.
I
was learning how to be fluent in
imagineing other lives.  I think
that's how books serveed me
well.
>> I was the only Cuban
American growing up in a Mexican
American neighborhood, and as
much as I
loved the poetry of
Mexico, my mother introduced me
to Kosi
Marte and I love all the
-- poets of Latin America and
from Spain, especially those who
were resisting the --
oppression.  So poetry was very
influential.  But I have to say
as far as being seen in a book,
I was 50 something when I read
memoir under the row palms.
That
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
would be the first time I read
something written specifically
about Cuba.  So we're here to
make sure no child ever has to
wait that long again.  Right?
Yeah.
When I was growing up I have a
clear memory of the first
Asians I ever saw in a book
which was that Five Chinese
Brothers
Book.
Okay.  Right.  Let's move on.
All right.
[Laughter]
Okay.  Do you have either a
book or books or an author or
authors who are your greatest
influence and your greatest
inspiration and why is that?  Is
it because of their craft?
Subject matter?  Theme?  Do you
have authors that you just sort
of hold up as your light?
Mitali, we'll start with you
this
time.
>> I just finished my annual
reread of Little Women again.
I love Jo March so much because
she was living in 19th
certainlyiry concurred conquered
conquered Massachusetts, but I
was living very
differently, but she chose to
write not to make money, but
despite all the pressures, and
any of you from South Asian
backgrounds know we basically
have three options, engineer,
doctor, and engineer.  Those are
our three options vocationally.
[Laughter]
So she pushed those
boundaries.  She loved her
sisters and
loved her writing.
For her, writing was something
she was never
going to give up on.  That's how
I felt about my writing.  A
refined
Bengali woman in that time did
want -- did not write
for money, we wrote for beauty.
She said, no, I'm going to
write for money and I'm going to
be independent.  I still love
her for that.
>> I think it's more her
life.  She only wrote two novels
and two short stories, but she
was a person of faith.  And her
works are infused with that
faith, but you'd never know it
if
you read her work.  In fact, in
many cases you'd think the
opposite, just because they're
so undidactic and so powerful.
So you read her books and you
put it
down andlike -- like, what
the hell just happened?
And a little while later you
begin to
notice things you didn't notice
before.  I think the ability to
see things differently is that
power that she gave me and that
I
would hope to emulate in my
writing.
>> That's why I'm a
Franciso Stork fan.  That's
exactly how
I would describe your work.
>> I would
say Marilyn Carveer would
inspire my work.  It was
the first time I read a verse
biography about someone who has
been neglected by history.
That's something I've really
striveed
to do, is to write about people
who have been forgotten and left
out of the history books.
And Carveer has not been left
out as
much as some of the people I've
felt inspired to write about,
but it was such a beautiful
thing she
did writing a biography in
verse instead of the kind of
formal nonfiction with footnotes
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
that a child might not feel
invited and welcomed to open the
pages and go, "Ah, this is
written for me." .
Have you ever told Marilyn that?
>> No, I haven't.
I have
>> I have a special --
affection for this book.  It's
incrediblely complex and
difficult to write.  It ends
with an
across an -- a
acrostic.  It will blow your
mind.
>> It comes across very simple
to understand for a child's
reading.
>> It's an amazing book.
Now we're going to move on to
our panel as writeers.  It was
very interesting to receive
these books and go through them
and
read them in preparation for
this -- symposium.
All three of them chose to use
more than one viewpoint.  We
have alternating chapters or
sections in all three books.  I
thought that was an interesting
thing to have in common.  I'd
like you to tell us about your
multiple characters and why you
chose them to be the ones to be
seen and heard in your book.
Margarita?
>> Well, Forest World is about
wilderness and in Cuba.  It's
set
in 2015 when President Obama had
initiated the peace-making
process between U.S. and Cuba.
And the only way I felt like I
could show this peace-making
process was by two children,
siblings, who had never met each
other before, and that is very
common where one grows up in
Miami and one in Cuba.  And so
even
though I have heard people say
they
don't like readings, I just
say take a minute to read one
very short poem in the sister's
voice.
She's grown up in a rural area
in Cuba.  The reason I
did multiple voices was to show
the difference between the U.S.
and Cuba.
Now, the American brother who
grew up in Miami, of course,
lives on his phone.  Everything
is about WiFi.  And video games.
And the girl who has grown up in
Cuba, of course, doesn't have
access to WiFi.
In rural Cuba, the fuel shortage
is to severe
that most people depend on
horse-drawn
vehicles or hitchhiking.
And nightfall, the clip clap of
horse hooves.  Rhythmic
flashes from dancing fire flies.
Around each curve the rising
moon.  Of long folktales,
stories of glow in the dark
dogs, and
magical horses.
My brother's fingers switch as
if he's longing
to send phone messages back to
his real home.  What was mama
thinking forcing him to spend
time here,
sharing our quiet
isolation?
>> Thank you. Who says people
don't like readings?
[Laughter]
I love them.
I love hearing the author read.
Right?
Okay.  Mitali.
So
>> You Bring the Distant Near
.  The person who comes to
Flushing Queens from Ben
Bangladesh.  Gee, I wonder where
I got that
idea?
[Laughter]
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
The heroic generation is the
first thing, those who come here
seeking, that bear the
sacrifice, the loss and the
cost.  The
narrative article really does
mostly belong to that first
generation, even though she's in
the first-person voice.
Then there are two girls who
are the second generation, which
is mine, the code switches.
They know about village Bengali
life and American life.
And they're gaining more agency
in this
culture than their parents had.
That's my generation.
And then the third generation is
my son's.
And how Bengali
are really are they?  And how
important is that?
People will often identify as
Indian, my sons.  But there are
22 major cultures and languages
in India.  So for them, their Be
Bengali identity really is --
it's getting lost.  So there's a
loss on both of those
generations.  It's that middle
generation
that straddles that.
So I wanted to see all of those
generations and how
immigration affects that.
>> Disappeared has two main
characters, shareia share --
Sarah is a young
journalist in Mexico.  We're
exploring so many women in a
certain period of time, their
disappearance.
The brother is a real go-getter,
track star and football star
star, I should say, and has this
little business of a craft
business, and the reason I had
two voices is because they were
kind of like two journeys.  One
of them is the physical journey
of Sarah and trying to stay
alive as she
begins to uncover some
of the causes for the
disappearing girls and her life
is
threatened.
And the other is more a moral
journey
and thetism the -- the
temptations that happen when
you're poor, to try to make
money
through drugs.
So there was both a physical
journey and kind of a moral
journey.  I think I needed two
voices.  And sometimes I think
like the two characters are just
part my myself.  Miliana is
who I am and Sarah is who I
would like to be.  [Laughter]
>> Nice. I'm hoping for
honesty with this next one, when
I
ask you to describe a typical
writing day.  For my honesty
will
be email, e bay, Tetris.  Open a
document.  Tetris.  Okay.
Right.
[Laughter]
What is your typical writing
session for you?  Mitali, we'll
start with you.
>> I'm motivated by shame.
[Laughter]
So recently, I have a strong
suspicion that my editor editor
and
agent have discovered that about
me.  Grace is here, my editor.
Without a deadline, I just -- I
do the same.  I have the same
schedule as you.
[Laughter]
So I work best under a
deadline.  If I don't make it,
there's
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
the horror of being ashamed.
Right?  And I work in coffee
shops
because I like that buzz.  So
there's an app that you can
download now called coffee shop
buzz that you can actually have
that on your phone.
[Laughter]
>> You're kidding. Oh, my God.
>> I'm one of those annoying
people in the Bay area.  I
shift coffee shops so I don't
get that look like, "Get an
office
office." That look.
I take up that space near the
plug.  That's me.
[Laughter]
>> Francisco?
>> I shouldn't say this because
Arturo Levine, my editor
is in the office.  I sit in
front of the computer and I say
I'm
going to do this for two hours
and see what happens.  I don't
do
quotas.  I just show up.
Sometimes I make it a sentence
or two
and sometimes it's a page and a
half.  I work in the mornings
and afternoons are for naps and
to-do lists for my wife.
>> Nice.
>> Who is the wower -- writeer
who said I spend all morning
putting a comma in?
>> Just take everything
Mitali said and reverse it.  I
need
peace, quiet, solitude.
I write with a pen by hand,
preferably
outdoors.
And daydreaming is the essence
of my process.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> Wow.
>> Because I'm sort of all over
over the map, I write my novels
on the computer, but I do poetry
and pictures.
>> I do, too.
>> Okay.
Now, the third section, which is
the panelists as
authors, which is different from
being writeers.  Right?
Okay.
I'd like you all to share a
favorite story about one
of your young readers that
illustrates our theme of the
power of
books.
I'm going to start on this one.
My favorite letter I've ever
gotten from a young reader.
Dear Ms. Park.  I was absent the
day we picked our author to
write to, and you were the only
one
left.
[Laughter]
So my question for you is do you
know Gary Paulson?
[Laughter]
But I was delighted that he
had a favorite author, right?
It
doesn't have to be me.  But they
have to have a favorite author.
Margarita, one of your young
readers?
>> I have received letters from
people asking me to pass
messages along to other authors,
also.  But for me the most
powerful moments have been when
I read a poem that's very
personal, especially when I read
from
from my memoir Enchanted here.
Very often a student will stand
up out of the crowd and read
their own poem to me, in front
of their classmates.  This has
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
happened to me on Skype.  It's
happened in person.  The most
powerful moments have been when
was a student who the teacher
said, later, told me privately,
"I didn't know that boy could
read.
" And he was writing his own
poetry.
And then also a young girl who
came up to me and recited a
poem about being a homesick
refugee.  And she was from
Syria.
And had just recently come to
the U.S.
So these kids that we are
speaking to and reading to,
they're
writing.  And we don't know that
unless we open up to them and
read our own work to them.
And share it very personally.
>> She felt so seen, that
girl.
Right.
>> I just Skyped with an
intergenerational book club in
Upstate New York.
So the librarian had arranged a
visit.  The
senior center had read my book
and teenagers had read my book.
They were discussing it together
and they were going to have an
Indian dance thing and a whole
day.  This is the first day this
has happened.  I gave my best
Skype, I thought.  And then they
started talking and they forgot
I was there.
[Laughter]
I was just this head on the
wall.  One of them started
sharing, one of the Indian women
there started sharing her story
of her arranged marriage.  She
started talking and all the
teens
were just focused on her story.
That was exciting to see that
connection.
The other part -- I love this
digital age and I'm a huge
social media geek.  When you go
to schools, and do you want a
spoiller about the book?  Are
you okay?  One of the characters
dies in the book.
And I was -- every book, every
father in
every book I write, is based on
my dad.  So we had just lost my
dad right before the book
launch.  So I had to go on -- on
tour
and visit all these schools and
I thought, oh, gosh, how am I
going to make it through?  You
try to be professional.  I went
to this school incal Kalamazoo
Michigan.
The electty --
electricity was out so everyone
was shivering in coats.  This
was a school with lots of
immigrants and lots of refugees.
I
shared my story and a
14-year-old boy's hand goes up.
I was
really trying to hide my grief
and I
thought I'd done a great
job.
He asked, in a cracky
14-year-old voice, I have a
question
question.
He said, I loved that dad.  Why
did that dad have to
die?  I thought, oh, gosh.  That
was hard.  I thought, thanks
for getting me choked up.
>> Yeah, really.
>> We're a very crying culture.
Feel free to jump in.  I
started writing -- crying in
front of all those 14-year-olds.
The best
part of that, I want to share
with you, is that every single
face in that room had so much
compassion, because I had lost
my
dad.
>> Why do you do this to me?
[Laughter]
>> This is a gift, my immigrant
gift to Americans.
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
[Laughter]
>> We cry.
>> Make him cry.
>> I think probably I wrote
this book about a young girl who
is recovering from depression,
day after a suicide attempt.  I
really wanted to make sure that
book -- I tried very hard
through various drafts to make
sure I got it right.
Approximate  -- if it
ended up in the hands of
somebody who was wondering what
to do
about life, that it would point
them in the right direction.
The emails I get sometimes from
kids that thank me for the book,
it makes it all worthwhile.
>> Yeah. Thank you. Thank
you all.
[Holding back tears.]
[Laughter]
This question has choice for
you.  Tell us about the next
book that's coming up for you or
what you're working on now?
Francisco?
>> This is the first time
I'm trying
to do a follow-up to
the previous book in Disappeared
the kids kind of get to the --
>> Yeah. I'm so excited.
>> They get to the border
and then so the next book is
their
lives, Their undocumented lives
in the United States.
>> Oh. Wow. Can't wait.
How far along are you?
[Laughter]
>> I'm on -- my editor is over
there so I can't say.
[Laughter]
>> It's due this summer. I
just asked him to define "summer
"summer" for me.
[Laughter]
>> Summer in the Southern
hemisphere.
[Laughter]
>> Okay. Margarita?
>> Margarita: My next first
novel is Jawza, the novel of the
Jutsut riots.
Their misnamed.
They should be called the sailor
riots.
It's about the sailors attacking
the Mexican youth.
They're enrageed enrageed about
interracial dancing, that
happened in my
home neighbor.  It comes out in
May.
And then next year, Soar
Soaring Earth which is a sequel
to my
childhood memoir Enchanted
Heir.
It's about the protests in the
1960s.  And it's really
embarrassing.  I will go into
hiding when it comes out.
[Laughter]
>> Can't wait for that one.
Okay.
>> I have my first picture
book comes out next year.  It's
called Gifts for Abuela.  It's a
California story.  It's about a
wall on the border and how --
it's about a little girl who
wants
to get a gift to her abuelita
across that wall.  That's my
next
book.
Then I'm working on Boy Wonder
and Cat Girl which is
multiple narrators.
I'm trying to get into the
Bollywood super
hero vibe.  It's about two teens
from Boston who
go to Calcutta.
They just confront some of the
trafficking that happens in the
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
city of my birth.
>> I'll get on this.
Next spring I have a picture
book
coming up.
There are dragons in Eastern
mythology and there's
dragons in Western mythology.
There are similarities but there
are also differences.
This is a little girl who has a
mother
from the East and a father from
the West.
It's my little mixed-
mixed-race dragon book.
[Laughter]
>> I want to give a shout-out
to Linda Sue Parker's parents
who are here, too.
[Laughter]
>> My parents are here.
[Applause]
>> My father got some love a
few months ago on twitter.  He
was asking for a good book to
read and I
gave him Angie Thomas
Thomas' the Gift You Give.  He
kept a list of things he didn't
understand and he asked me,
first, "what is this hose?"
So that was a fun
conversation.
[Laughter]
We're going to move now to a
lightening round.  The questions
thus far I did give the
panelists so they could think
about it a
little bit.  These they had not
seen.  They start easy and
they're going to get a little
harder.  All right?
IPhone or Android.?
>> EyeIPhone. I'm an Apple
girl.
>> A iPhone.
>> Twitter or Facebook?
>> Twitter.
>> Facebook.
>> PROFESSOR: Okay.
R2D2 or --
>> That's a terrible
question.  How can you choose?
>> I like living organisms.
[Laughter]
>> R2D2 I think.
>> Okay.
Chachala or Kilmunger.
>> I have no idea.
>> Pass.
>> Then just pass.
>> What is the question?
[Laughter]
>> Go see Black Panther.
>> Oh, man. I feel
terrible.
>> Kilmuger. All right.
[Laughter]
>> Your Hogwarts house?
>> I read Harry Potter, but
that was a long time ago.  I
don't remember.
>> Ravenclaw, I think bit.
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
>> Is Mytherine is term?
>> Slytherine.
[Laughter]
>> The three of us are going to
to a
matinee of Black --
Panther.
>> That was a joke.
>> What do you think I am?
>> A raveen claw.
>> I am a raveen claw.
Desert island or pop recording
artist.
>> Desert island, whatever that
is.
[Laughter]
>> This is a complicated
question.
>> In other words, what
recording artist would you more
--
>> Oh, I see.
[Laughter]
>> You got to help me out,
Jason.
>> That's my fault. It was
unclear.  The greatest love song
of all all time: Let's stay
together by the reverend Al
Green.
>> Anybody else have one? A
song?  Recording artist, album?
>> Benny Moray.
>> Okay.
>> Let it be.
>> Oh, wow, very nice.
>> Last request meal?
>> That's so easy. I'll go
first.
My mom's
cauliflower and
potato kurry.
>> Ice cream.
>> Rice and beans and hot
chocolate.
>> Shayshek.
[Laughter]
Okay.  Maybe you kind of
already answered this.  I'll ask
it
again.  An author or book you
wish everyone in the room would
read.
>> Hmm.
I'll start with with the Book
Thief is one of my
favorite books.
>> I'm judging a national
book awards this year so I have
to
be really silent.  I can't say
anything.  I did love both of
their books, though.  I have to
put a plug in.
These are both
excellent books.
>> Hold on a second.
[Laughter]
>> I have a special love for
Brown Girl Dreaming by
Jacqueline Woodson because I
think it's one of the most
important books of the century,
but also she was writing it at
the same time that I was writing
Enchanted heir and I didn't
know and I'm sure she didn't
know that we were doing verse
memoirs at the same time.  So I
feel like that says that at this
point in time people from
marginalizeed communities are
writing
in poetry because I can't speak
for her
but I believe that the
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
harshness of history requires a
beautiful language and a soften
softening of the blow that comes
with poetry.  I think that
maybe we're facing things that
couldn't be faced in prose.
>> Oh. Interesting. Wow. I
guess if I were answering I
would just say in honor of this
event, anything by Walter Dean
Myers.  Absolutely.
[Applause]
And this is the last lightening
round question.  It's a good
one.  What's on your head
headstone?
[Laughter]
>> It's easy because it's my
twitter bio-and my Facebook
bio.
It's just going to say: Beloveed
like you.
>> Oh, that's so nice.
>> Peace.
>> He tried to be human.
>> Wow. Great. Great
words.
>> But did he succeed?
>> I need your help for that.
[Laughter]
>> Okay. We're almost finished
and ready to hand on to the
next exciting part of our
morning, but I'll just ask you
to
finish by keeping in mind our
theme of the power of books.
You
have an audience here of readers
and especially teachers and
librarians who work with young
people.  What one thing would
you
like to tell them to take home
to the young people about your
work on your particular book?
Margarita?
>> Just that verse novels are
interactive.  The white space
on the page is not empty.
It contains my emotions and the
read
reader's emotions.
And you can invite students to
write their
own poems in response.
They can jump in at any point on
any
page and write their own poems.
They can write the missing
voices, because I certainly
can't do it all.  There's the
old
addage that a poem is never
finished; it's just abandoned.
The
same is true of a poetry book.
It's not finished.  There's room
for them to come in and write.
>> Do you want to go ahead?
>> No. You should be last.
I think it's not about my books
but I think the action item I
would say is just to try to
mentor
a young person in your life,
just listen
to their works and word
words, help them along as best
you can.  You don't have to be a
writing coach.  But just one
young person that you find.
>> Jacqueline Woodson says
she's
trying to change the world
one reader at a time.
>> Yeah, that's great.
I say play around with
mirrorrors.
I found unexpected mirrors in
books and so will the kids you
serve.
I say let kids roam freely.
Don't limit them to be just
an ethnic mirror.  They're going
to find that.  I say play
around with your collections and
displays.
I read from many in
my career, we just don't have an
Indian reading population,
Mitali, so that's why.  I don't
hear that anymore.  Our books
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
are for all readers.  Really --
[Applause]
>> I am so thankful to WNDB --
We Need Diverse Books.  We've
been writing for years and years
and years.  Because I don't
hear that anymore.
Let your readers roam freely.
Find the
mirrors.
And just offer them diversity in
books.
>> I'm giving you the perfect
ending because most of us use
that windows and mirrors
metaphor, which has been so
incrediblely
useful.  And here with us today
we have the originator of that
phrase, Dr. Bishop.
[Applause]
He was doing this work before
most of us knew it was work.
So I guess a break now before
our actual Walter Award sir
money starts.
I hope you had a great time, and
I think we did,
too.
>> When Linda Sue Parker
said she wasn't going to do the
basic cookie cutter panel, and
we were in for a good ride, that
was true.
You have taken us on a journey,
all of you, and you
made us laugh and cry, and I'm
glad none of you became the
doctor or engineer you might
have been.
[Laughter]
I wanted to say speaking on
behalf of We Need Diverse Books
it's been a pleasure to
cosponsor
this symposium with the
Library of Congress.
We especially appreciate Leanne
Potter
with the Library of Congress.
We're going to take a
15-minute break.
-- coffee and tea in
the back.
We've also set up book sales,
and please go ahead and
purchase those.
We will be -- the authors will
very nicely be
signing during the reception
that will follow.  We want to
make
sure that they have time to --
we're celebrating them during
the
reception.  We don't want to
make them work the whole time.
So no personalizing.
And also, no photos for this
signing.
And then we're going to try
to do that efficiently and then
let them enjoy and mingle with
all of you.
So see you back here in about
15 minutes.  And thank you.
And thank you.  Let's give
one more hand for these
wonderful
panelists.
[Applause]
[Break
taken]
>> If everyone would please
take their seats.  Thank you.
>> Hello.
And welcome.
There's nothing like an unruly
crowd of librarians, teachers,
educators, and publishers.
Networking is really great and
we're going to do it afterwards
at the reception to thank you
very much for your patience.
I'm Kathy Weinberg and I'm the
co
director of the We Need
Diverse Books Walter Awards.
We welcome you to the third
Walter
Dean Myers award for outstanding
children's literature.
It's fitting to start with an
often heard quote from Walter
Dean Myers, whose legacy we
honor with this award: Reading
is
not optional.
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
This award says that children
finding and seeing themselves
in books is also not optional.
We need diverse books founded
with
with the hashtag, with 21
people and now it has grown to a
global presence.  We know how
global it is because one of our
founders and the head of We Need
Diverse Books,
Ellen Hong, is out of town at a
book festival.  I
hope she's watching on the live
stream.  Everyone say hi to
Ellen.
So We Need Diverse Books has
brought positive change to the
publishing world and the books
being published.
And We Need Diverse Books
started the Walter Award three
years ago we had for your first
year under 40 books considered
for consideration.
For The Walter 2017 we had 76
commissions
for The Walter.
And for Walter 2018, while we
did add the category of younger
reader, our submissions were
over 180 books.
So that's the beginning of
progress.
We have a lot of thank yous to
hand out today.  First, to the
Library of Congress for their
hospitality, especially Dr.
Carla
Hayden, Lee Ann Potter, Clay
Penchak, Sarah and Sasha.  We
could not do this without the We
Need Diverse Books staff and
volunteers.
A big thanks
to Carolyn Richman
, Judy Striker, and
Christine.
We also couldn't do it without
Karen Brown.
And we want We Need Diverse
Books volunteers to please stand
up.  All We Need Diverse Books
volunteers, please stand up so
we
can thank you.
[Applause]
Thank you.
We want to take a moment to
honor the
memory of of of of the legacy of
Walter Dean Myers and thanks his
family and friends for the
continued support of the award.
Of course, the award would
not be possible without our most
talented and slight slight
slight
slightly bleary-eyed judges who
have read some
wonderful books today.
Maria Salvador is over there,
the
codirector.
And other members of the judges
are here.  Would
you please stand up so we can
thank you?
[Applause]
And one we're on a thank you
role, I want to say a big thanks
to the publishers, many of whom
are in your audience today.
Thank you to listening We Need
Diverse Books and for supporting
the need of diversity in
children's literature.
One last things to our audience,
educators, and readers, and
librarians.  We could not spread
the We Need Diverse Books word
and put diverse authors and
characters
in the hands of children
without your help.  Thank you.
We have a wonderfully full
program and to start it out I
would like to introduce Mark
Sweeney.  While we miss Dr.
Hayden,
we're very appreciatetive of his
time and interest in the
ceremony
ceremony.
Es works  He works with the
Library of Congress and, plus,
serves as the director of
preservation.  Welcome, Mr.
Sweeney.
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
>> Well, good morning,
everyone here.  The energy in
the
room is really infectious.
I'm pleased to add my voice to
the
corps
chorus of choice voices
welcomeing welcomeing you here
today.
We are here with We Need
Diverse Books to highlight
diversity
in children's literature.  Just
four years ago, We Need Diverse
Books began as a
simple hashtag on twitter.
Today, it's a
501(c)3 with writeers and people
who span the globe.  The We Need
Diverse Books team seeks to
create a world in which every
child
can see themselves in the pages
of a book.
The Library of Congress
shares this goal.  We are proud
to
have hosted this morning's
symposium on diversity and
children's
literature and also to be
hosting this ceremony.
Both events highlight and
promote books that broaden our
notions of diversity and engages
in meaningful conversations
about them.
To honor exemplary diverse
books, We Need Diverse Books
published The Walter the Walter
Dean
Myers award for outstanding
children's
-- literature, The Walters.
He was a recipient of the corps
Coretta Scott King award winner
--
and every child a reader in
2012.
We're delighted the emcee for
this ceremony is a current
national ambassador
National Ambassador for Young
People's
Literature, Jacqueline
Woodson.  And I'm delighted to
introduce her.  Jacqueline is a
four-time Newbery honor
Medalist.
Corps
-- her platform, reading equals
hope and change, what's your
equation, encourages young
people
to think about and beyond the
moment that they're living in.
The power they possess and the
impact reading can have in
showing them ways in which they
can create the hope and change
they want to see in our world.
Please join me in welcomeing
Jacqueline Woodson to the
podium.
Thank you.
[Enthusiastic
applause]
>> Good morning. What an
honor.  Okay.  I would be remiss
to not do this for my personal
panelists.
You'll all get it after this
afternoon's viewing.  [Laughter]
Oh, man.
That was the best symposium
ever.
Ever.  I didn't
space out once.
[Laughter]
It really was the best.  So
thank you.  Thank you.  What an
honor to be in the room.
And what an honor to be back at
the Library of Congress.
There's so much love in the
room.  This is a place that as a
young person I never came to.
I never thought it was for me.
And to Carla Hayden's staff
here, the energy is amazing now.
And to look around this room and
to see how diverse it is, to be
in this moment of We Need
Diverse Books is everything.  It
is a
dream.  And beyond.
So I just want to say to the
young people in the room, hold
fast to dreams, because this is
what they become.
And yall are amazing.  Amazing.
I am still high on on the march
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
on the national walkout and all
the work the young people are
doing to change the world.  And
all the work my fellow writeers
are doing to keep us here.
So what an absolute honor.
I have a speech written because
I don't get nervous unless
they tell me that it's being
televised.
Suddenly, the intimas
is the the intimac
intimacy is gone.  But all the
folks out there.  I see you.
[Applause]
We present our first book
selller of the year award.  So
this
is going a little longer.
It is a true universally -- see,
this is what happens.
[Laughter]
And for the Newbery, for thecal
da
the Caldecott, ask the and the
award being
given this year, Laura Engles
Wilder you have to write a
speech
a couple months beforehand so
they can record it.  I guess
you're not supposed to mess up
on it like I'm messing up right
now.  Just the idea of writing
something long before you get in
the room with the people you're
going to say it to.  You don't
know how the world is going to
change.  It's changing to
quickly
quickly.  What you write two
months before a speech could be
not
so relevant anymore.
But this is all very
relevant.  I do digress.
That was all to cover up.
It's a very New York thing to
kind
of knock you off track for a
minute.
[Laughter]
It's truly universally
acknowledged that every diverse
book
is in need of a book selller to
sell it.  Book selllers might be
one of the most important as
people who both curate
collections
and get books into the hands of
readers who will purchase them.
They have the power to create
best selllers, but more vitally
they have the power to
represent.  Meaning that
children can go
to their stores and either
search in vain for books that
reflect
their world or smile when they
see themselves on the shelves.
Today, the first book selller
of the year award, a prize
created because our organization
wanted to recognize the role
that book selllers have as
driveers of the publishing
industry.
No one can read or buy a book
they've never heard of.
This is our thank you to the
independent book selllers of our
country for championing and, I
might be mispronouncing that,
because that's not a word I
wrote.  I usually write words I
pronounce a lot.
[Laughter]
But it means being champions of.
The cause and diverse books and
showing that they can, in
fact, sell.  We do buy books.
[Laughter]
The winner of the first annual
We Need Diverse Books selller
of the year award is Sarah of
carriage books and more in
Atlanta
Atlanta.  I love this bookstore.
I don't have enough time to
talk about how much I love
Carris books.  One of the early
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
bookstores I visited and the
community that happens there.
I'm
very proud to present this
award.
As the oldest feminist bookstore
in the country, it's an
institution that's proud and
open about its mission to
reflect
the wide spectrum of
experiences, lives, and
familyies.
Their excellence in the
support of diverse books is
evident
in the types of events that it
programs,
in the antiracist
resistance and LGBT book list,
in its community outreach to
librarians and schools and
teach-in's, and, of course, in
its
collection which honors all
types of diversity.
We Need Diverse
Books is honored to present
Sarah and Carris books with two
awards, one for them to keep,
and one
for them to keep at Carris
books until the next book
selller is nominated and then
you have
to give it back.  Sorry.
Thank you, Sarah, and Carris
books.
[Applause]
No speech.
>> I think you have to stand
here and let me take a picture
with you.
>> Sorry. We didn't
practice that part.  Sorry.
[Laughter]
>> Thank you.
[Applause]
>> You might want to check your
luggage.  I've been stopped
for these.
And now we move on to the
Walter Awards.  Right?  Am I --
okay.
[Laughter]
>> Any way you like.
>> Thank you.
[Laughter]
So now we move on to the Walter
Awards and we start with my
brother from another mother,
Jason Reynolds.
[Enthusiastic applause].
>> Who is here with his
fabulous mother.  Jason Reynolds
is
a New York times bestselling
author, a Newbery honor -- a
Newbery honor -- a Newbery award
honoree.  You know what, I'm
just drop the honoree.  Make it
easy.  Jason is a Newbery award
winner.
[Laughter]
A prince award nominee, a
national
book award nominee, a -- a
two-time Walter Dean Myers award
winner, and the recipient of
multiple Coretta Scott King
honors.  I think there was one
year
you got two at the same
ceremony, right?  Yeah.  He's
not
messing around, yall.  If you're
going to half step it, don't
step at all.
[Laughter]
He was the 2017 spokesperson for
Indies first.  And he's
brilliant and also not so hard
too to look at.
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
[Laughter]
And will serve as the national
spokesperson for the 2018
celebration of school library
month,
sponsored by the American
association of school
librarians.
We see you AASL.
He has a number of books,
including: As brave as you for
everyone.
I don't know that one.
>> It's not out yet.
>> Oh, okay. It's not out
yet.
[Laughter]
And also long way down, which
received both a a new a Newbery
and a
Prince honor.
So I have a 10-year-old son who
reads differently.  He listen
listens to audio books nonstop.
And every time I ask him,
what's in his ear?  Jason
Reynolds.  Jason Reynolds.  But
you
listened to that all right." I'm
listening to it again." Jason
Reynolds.
But he loves this writeer, as do
so many of us.
Congrats,
Jason.
[Enthusiastic applause.]
>> Thank you.
Hi, everybody.  It's a whole lot
of yall in
here this year.
[Laughter]
So I have a few minutes to say a
few words.  Thank you to the
Library of Congress and to We
Need Diverse Books.  I'm forever
grateful for the work you've
done.  Thank you judging panel
and
committee.
It is never lost on me how
fortunate I am any time
anything like this happens.  I
am truly grateful.  Thank you to
my mama.
[Enthusiastic applause]
>> I like to always tell
people it's important to make
sure
everybody who knows me knows
her.  It's important to do that,
at
the end of the day.
All of us are -- our lives are
sort of
fleeting.  At the end of the
day, when she's out of here,
when
I'm out of here, I want her
legacy to be as solid and
perpetual
as my own.  It's important.
Shout out to my mom.  Thank you
to
everybody who has been up here,
all the honorees, autopsy the
winners, this is so cool to be
around such important and
interesting people.
And of course, the great
Jacqueline Woodson, these the
only
person I know who is so deck
decorated, everything, has all
the award
awards, and yet still somehow
seems to not take herself so
seriously.  It's good to
understand what we're doing but
the
awards don't necessarily change
our character, or shouldn't, at
least.  Who we are is who we
are.  I'm thankful to you of
being
a big sister to my in in my
literary world.
Also my agent is here and my
editor both of whom are
responsible for all the work
that I do.  Because you goet to
go go to do
that, right?
Because somebody will be like,
"You didn't even
thank the committee."
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
All that is over.
[Laughter]
So I've been working on a new
book.  I can't talk about it.
[Laughter]
But I have all this stuff
happening in my brain and it's
moving around and I'm trying to
figure out what to do with it.
I've been really working on this
-- we all know the adage if a
tree falls in the forest and it
doesn't
make -- and nobody is there to
hear it,
does it make a sound?  I've done
some research on it and I think
it's fascinating.  I've been
digging around to figure out
what
does that mean for my life or
work?  What exactly are they
talking about?
Turns  Turns out, though it is a
philosophical
statement, it's actually a
scientific statement.
Scientists are
saying if a a tree falls in in
the forest, there's a vibration
from
that impact and that vibration
travels to -- yall need to make
an announcement?
Exactly.
The tree falls, hits the
ground, there's a vibration.
That
vibration travels to the eardrum
and when it hits the eardrum,
it makes the sound.
If the vibration -- does not hit
the
eardrum, technically, a sound is
not made.
So the scientists are saying,
technically, then it doesn't
make a sound if it doesn't hit a
eardrum.
For me, it makes sense sort of,
except somehow in that
argument it sort ophidiasis
qualifies of
-- disqualifies the idea of the
sound being
made in the first place.
So if a tree is a growing
thing, once it hits in the
ground,
there's a vibration made.
Whether someone heard it or not
is of
less importance than the fact
the vibration was made.  So say
it
doesn't, then it disqualifies
the life of the said tree.
Right?
[Applause]
Now, from a philosophical
standpoint, which is other
argument
argument, which is is the
colloquial argument most of us
make when
we say this, we look at it as a
philosophical statement.  From a
philosophical standpoint I think
that perhaps we're not
necessarily asking the right
questions.  Right?  It's like
that
seems like such a limited and
simplified question to be asking
about a tree that falls in the
forest with no one around to
hear
it.  Because there are other
questions, extenuating questions
we
should be asking ourselves to
better understand the context in
which a tree is falling in the
forest with no one around to
hear
it.
For instance, is the wind
blowing?  For instance, was the
tree struck by lightning?  For
instance, is there something
eating at the base of the tree
which makes it less strong?  For
instance, are their termites
eating the tree from the inside
out
out?  All of this would help us
better understand whether or not
it matters if a sound is made or
not if a tree falls in a forest
with no one there to hear it.
Now, let's transpose tree for
child.  Right?
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
>> Bring it home.
>> From a scientific standpoint
if a child falls, and no one
is there to hear it, does it
make a sound?  According to the
scientist, the child does not.
According to what I'm arguing,
though, if we say a child does
not make a sound or the child's
impact on that ground does not
create a vibration, then we
disqualify the life of said
child.
Now, from a philosophical
standpoint, if a child falls,
does
it make a sound, again, I think
we need to ask more questions.
Number one, was there wind
blowing?  Was there something
there
pushing the child?
Was there something, a force, an
unseen
force forcing the child down?
Was there something eating at
the
child's base?  Something there
that maybe we don't know eating
at the child?  Were there
termites involved eating from
the
child inside out?
Was lightening striking anywhere
in the
vicinity?  Was anything on fire?
Was the ground weakened by
anything?
And lastly, lastly, why aren't
anyone
-- like, where are the
people?  Right?  If a tree falls
in the forest and no one is
around, does it make a sound?
The question is why is no one
around?  Where are the people?
Where is everyone?  Right?
Because that's the question
that we should be asking.  That
is what Long Way Down is
actually about.
Everyone is saying, oh
oh, it's about a kid in Ghana --
no, no, no.  This is about the
kid that we judge every single
day, it's best we ask about
them.
This book is not about any
child; this book is about you.
You
read the book.  Whatever you
think happens to this kid at the
end of this book has more to say
about you than that child.  Do
your work to make sure our
babies have a fair shot.  That's
all
I ask for.
I also want to say quickly to
Margarita, am I friend, at the
end of the day she could
probably explain the power of
verse and
novels far better than I could.
I think the job she holds is
very important and I think she
understands the power of poetry
and the power of verse and the
force in the way that I hope to
mature to some day.  It's
important that she know that, as
well.
I appreciate you all.  Thank you
all, very, very much.  Have a
good day.
[Applause]
note Ghana
>> I know. You can't just
drop mics that are attached to a
podium.
[Laughter]
>> Thank you, Jason.
I think it's a good moment to
just bring the the ancestors
into
the room.
I do this as often as I can.
When you hear the
powerful words spoken by our
writeers, I think it's important
for
us all to remember the people
who came before us and how
important they were to who we
are now, to being able to stand
here.  And the people who have
left this world but still walk
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
with us.  So if we could just
take two minutes and just shout
out a name of someone who you
want to bring back into the room
or who is already in the room
with us, I think that would be
fitting in this moment of
remembering Walter Dean Myers.
That's
the name I'll say.
>> Virginia Hamilton
.
[Multiple names away from
microphone]
>> John A Williams.
>> Mary Anne Woodson.
>> Robin Smith.
>> Thank you.
Welcome home.
Carole Boston Weatherford.
[Applause]
>> I just appreciate your
power in the room.  So I just
have
loved your work forever and I'm
so grateful to be in the room
with us.  Carole Boston
Weatherford is a New York times
bestselling author and poet.
Her numerous books for children
include Becoming Billie
Holiday and Voice of Freedom
spirit of
the civil rights movement,
illustrated
by Ikwa Holmes.  Such an
amazing both.  Among others.
And Carole Boston Weatherford
lives in Fayetteville North
Carolina and has been writing
and changing the world for many,
many years and I so appreciate
you.
[Applause]
>> Thank you, Jacqueline.
Why'd you make me follow the
philosopher?
After I heard Jason's speech, I
asked Eric, you
want to go next?
[Laughter]
>> I'm going to start with an
epithet.
epitaph.  1938.  If this
proverb, a book is a gardeen
carried in
a pocket is true, then
Schomburg had a green thumb and
a harvest of pride.  There was
no field of human endeavor he
did not till with his determined
hand, that he did not sew with
seeds of curiosity.  Or that he
did not water with a growing
sense of African awareness and
heritage.
If a book is a garden carried in
a pocket, then
Schomburg yielded a bumper crop,
blanketed mount kill la minute
jaro with African
violated violets.
If I had African violets I would
certainly give them to We Need
Diverse
Books, to my agent and
publisher and my family and
friends and to librarians who
have
used my books and teachers who
have used my books.
And also my
collaborator Eric Velasquez, who
pitched this book to me.
Schomburg brings my work full
circle, just as does this
award
ceremony.
His teacher in fifth grade told
him his African American
ancestors had no history worth
noting.  I was told something
similar by an 8th grade teacher.
I went to an exclusive quake
quaker school in Baltimore and I
was the only one who had
transferred from public school.
I got my paper back and the
teacher gave me a B, and offered
only one comment: Did you write
this?
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
Obviously, he had expected
less of me.  Ever since, I have
striveed to use my pen to affirm
my heritage and culture.  When I
was an inspiring children's book
writeer, before I had anything
published by adult poetry, I
studied the work of Walter Dean
Myers.  Among the mentor texts I
turned to
were Brown Baby --
I'm sorry.
Brown Angels, Harlem to Harlem,
and
One More Rivet
Across.
Many years later, 20 years to be
exact, I did research at
Howard University.  And to the
Library of Congress prints and
photographs department, in this
very building.
I was looking for images to
accompany my poems.  Instead, I
found pictures that begged for
words.  Some were of historic
figures.  Others were of
everyday people whose names had
been
lost.  I wrote poems to give
them voices.  I began right then
and there collecting images and
stories.
I'm going to close with a poem
from that book.  That first
led me to the Schomburg center.
Remember the bridge.
Remember the bridge that your
ancestors
crossed, the sweat that was
spillled and the lives that were
lost
lost.  Remember the slaves who
raised corn and cotton.  Keep
singing their songs so they
won't be forgotten.  The under
ground railroad that passed
through at night.  The signs and
conductors that guided slaves'
flight.  Remember the soldiers
who fought though they knew they
might not be free when the
battle was through.
Remember the old souls who
handed down tale
tales, the bold men and women
who blazed their own trails from
the south to the north, from
farm to big
city, with satchels of
dreams and new use for pity.
Remember the boot blocks blacks,
the
industryious laborers, remember
the housemaids who scrubbed
dirty
floors, the readers who spoke
out.
Remember the hard way the
answer cess stores came,
snatched from the mother land,
bound in
chains.
Remember the voyage, the
capture, the chase, young
warriors who vanished without
even a trace.  Long shadows on
shorelines and foot prints in
sand.
Forget not to temples of
Africa's past
.  Ebony statues and -- hands
reach across water.
Hearts sing a new song.  Thank
you.
[Applause]
>> Posing for the picture
thing is the most awkward part.
Right?  Thank you so much for
that, Carol.  That poem was
lovely
lovely.
Oh, man.
Eric Velasquez.
One cool thing is the children's
book writing community is small.
So we all know each other.  A
lot of us know each other.  A
lot of us go way way back.  And
when we get together we have a
lot of catching up to do.  So it
was so great to be reunited last
night and to be able to gossip
about all that stuff we didn't
get a chance to talk about, and
to catch up.
And I want to make a point about
the importance of picture
books.  I feel like when I read
Schomburg I learned so much that
I didn't know.  And I think
sometimes we think picture books
are
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
for young people.
They really are for everyone.
[Applause]
And they're a great way to teach
about the narrative arc.
There's a great way to teach
poetry.  So many of the forms
are
so poetic poetic, so get these
books into the hands of writeers
of all
ages.  They're ground breaking
and important and world
changing.
Eric Velasquez is the
illustrateor of numerous books
for
children, including several
previous collections with Carole
Boston Weatherford.
He won the illustrator award for
his
illustrations of the Piano Man
if you haven't seen and read it,
you must.
Written by Debbie Chocolate.  He
also is the
illustrateor of the award
winning Grandma'S Gift people
born in
Harlem are so the real thing to
me.  I was always so jealous of
black people born in Harlem.
[Laughter]
His work is mind blowing and he
is mind blowing and I'm so
glad to share this stage with
him and present him with his
award
award.
[Applause]
>> Wow. There is a lot of
you in here.
[Laughter]
>> Okay.
Well, I have my speech.  Okay.
So I wanted to
start with those that didn't see
the video that I recorded for
the We Need Diverse Books
organization, that my wish and
my wish
is that in my lifetime we'll
replace this word "diversity,"
especially in books, with the
word" normal." That's a simple
concept.
[Laughter]
Diversity in my house didn't
really exist.  I grew up in a
Spanish speaking household but
we went to the movies to see
American films that spoke
English.  Watched Spanish
speaking
television.
Listened to salsa music but also
listened to the
Temptations.  It's like, wow,
wait, diversity is like
everything
everything?  But that's my life.
But that's my wish for all of
you, that lots of normal.
Okay.  So now to my thank yous.
So I want to thank the We
Need Diverse Books organization.
As well as the Walter Dean
Myers judging committee.
Which is named after my friend
Walter
Dean Myers.
Thank you to Reuben my agent for
helping this project find
a home.
I would also like to thank our
editor,
art directors
for their hard work and
dedication to this project.
And to the public relations team
for
their tireless efforts.
To master author Carole Boston
Weatherford, thank you for
writing a glorious manuscript.
You truly outdid yourself with
this one, our fifth
collaboration.
I want to thank the love of my
life,
Elizabeth Rosario, not
only for posing as Elizabeth and
Philis Whitley, but also for
the love, support, reassurance,
and strength.  You are my rock.
[Applause]
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
Okay.
I first became aware of Arturo
Schomburg in the third
grade.
My teacher, Ms.
Holmes, kept a poster of him on
her
classroom room, along with
Martin Luther King junior and
Malcolm
X and Marcus Garvey, where he
has the uniform.  Yeah.
But what a gift the day she said
to me that Arturo Schomburg
and I shared something in
common.
That we both had roots in
Puerto Rico.
Has she continued with a brief
talk on Arturo
Schomburg for the first time in
my life I found a hero that
looked like me and that I can
identify with.
I could not wait to get home and
ask my grandma if she knew
this great man responsible for
the library on 135th street in
Harlem.
I asked her, thinking I would
throw
her off with the name.  [
[Speaking Spanish]
Of course, that man was a
genius, she said.
[Spanish]
The name place we come from.
However, aside from
Schomburg's collection of books
and
artifacts, she didn't know much
more about the man.
37 years later, while at the
Schomburg Center attending a
performance of the last poets
with Elizabeth and her good
friend
Sheena, Sheena turns to me and
says, you know, there are no
children's books on Arturo
Schomburg.  You know, you ought
to
think about doing that book.
[Laughter]
Suddenly, I realized that this
was
the hand handsome man in that
poster that I would stare at day
after day in the third grade.
That genius that my grandmother
talked about.
I contacted Carol immediately
and
asked her to write me a
manuscript on Schomburg.  That
was 2006.  We submitted the
project to several publishing
houses and we were rejected
everywhere.
This is just the story about a
man who collected books?  So
boring.  Can't you jazz him up a
little bit?  You know?
Well, it didn't happen then.
In 2014, our now agent Ruben
Sepher
decided to give it a
another try.
After a lot of work, a new
manuscript and sketches,
Schomburg: The Man Who Built a
Library
found a home at Candle
Candlewick Press.
What a journey.
However, through Carol's word I
truly
discovered Schomburg's genius
and a true gift to all of us.
This project changed my life
in so many ways.  I even ended
up in the hospital, didn't I?
I even met Dean Schomburg,
Arturo
Schomburg's grandson, who is now
a man in his 70s.  I met his
daughter and her son Miles.  So
that's Schomburg's great great
grandson.
So I conclude with Arturo
Schomburg,
I say, gracias...[
gracias...
[Spanish].
[Applause]
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?
cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
>> Oh.
Okay.  Awesome.
na-na-na-na-na to the
publishers who said no.
[Laughter]
I bet you you'll look quite hard
at the next book that comes
across.
[Laughter]
So now it is my great pleasure
to present the honor awards.
I don't have any bio-s for them.
We're just going to roll with
this for the authors.  Oh,
Caroline.
[Laughter]
Okay.  No, no, no.  I know
you all are tired of sitting.
I'm
going to present them.
Margarita, Mitali, and Francisco
have
done amazing things in
literature.  I want to first
present
Margarita who is our young
people's poet laureate.  She's
the
first Latino -- why does it say
Latino?
Isn't it Latina and Lat
Lati in-X?  We're only talking
about a woman?
>> In Spanish, it includes
both.
>> Okay.
Okay.
>> So okay. Margarita is
amazing and I'm very
happy --
[Laughter]
-- to present her with this
award.
[Applause]
>> Thank you.
>> I just want to say again
how fabulous you all were on the
panel.
And how eye-opening it was.  For
those of you who missed
it, that revolution is going to
be televised, right?  Hopefully
you'll get to watch it.
She has written for-- Mitali, we
know where she lives.  We got
her bio- when she
was doing the panel.  I was
beyond honored to present Mitali
with this award.
She is the author of several
books, including
You Bring the Distant Near.
[Applause]
>> And Francisco, who is just
amazing
.  He has won awards.
I didn't know about this
particular book until my
16-year-old
daughter came to me and said,
you need to read this book.  I
was
mad she knew something I didn't.
So lovely and world changing
and I'm so honored that you're
here.
>> Thank you.
[Applause]
>> So thanks, all, for being
here.  And we're going to
conclude, but don't get up off
your seats, yet.  But thank you.
Thank you, authors, for changing
the world.  Thank you,
committee, for changing the
world.  Thank you We Need
Diverse
Books for being born.
And thank you teachers,
librarians, write
writers, readers, for supporting
the work we're doing.
[Applause]
>> Thank you. Jacqueline
just did the unimagineable.  She
finished an award ceremony
early.
We're sending her over to the
capitol.  Okay?  Yeah?  Things
will be running better.
[Laughter]
http://upload.youtube.com/closedcaption?cid=pk87-p4dr-fpke-emzp
But fortunately, we're ready
to start the reception.  We'll
start.
We'll have more time for
mingleing and getting able to
talk to the authors.  They're
going to go over to the book
signing table, after they go
over with the judges and have a
photo with the judges.
So Walter honor or award winner
being,, if you go over there and
get
a picture with the judges, that
would be nice.  We'll do that
first.  Then they'll go over and
they'll be signing.  Strict
orders, they'll just be signing,
and no photos.  I'm sorry about
that, but we want them to have
time to enjoy themselves because
they certainly earned it.
So thank you, all.  You've
been a wonderful audience.  And
thank you very much to the
Library of Congress.  Thank you.
[Applause]